ja das ende von gruner sommer ist
spannend infektionszahlen steigen
langsam tausende demonstrieren gegen
korona maßnahmen urlaubsrückkehrer
bringen frisches virus mit nach hause
und das teilweise unbemerkt durch dem
ist in bayern diese große test panne gab
und kaum sind die ersten schulen wieder
auf wohl noch schon die ersten wieder
geschlossen das ist alles nicht so toll
aber meanwhile den usa könnte die zahl
der todesopfer sowie 3000 menschen nach
und raffinierter zeichnet mehr als zwei
millionen karat ist die zahl der neuen
route bereitet der blick ins ausland
zeigt uns zwei dinge erstens wir haben
in deutschland offenbar vieles richtig
gemacht und zweitens das was wir bisher
erlebt haben an todesfällen andock down
schäden ist noch lange nicht alles was
dieses der virus kann wir stehen also
gerade an einem punkt der pandemie in
dem das alte deutsche sprichwort gilt
lasst uns keine panik schieben aber auch
bitte nicht verpacken eine altes
sprichwort aber immer wieder gut also
wie schaffen wir es nicht mehr in die
partie zurück zu rutschen
genau darum geht es in diesem video und
ich verspreche euch im gegensatz zu
unserem letzten kroner video ende dieses
hier wirklich hoffnungsvoll
denn es gibt neue tests die unser
komplettes leben auf den kopf
also positiv auf den kopf auf die füße
also ihr wisst schon
die alles verändern könnten stell dich
vor bevor kinder in die kita oder schule
gehen spucken sie beim eingang auf so
einen test und kinder mit positivem
ergebnis wären direkt nach hause
geschickt
aber eins nach dem anderen holte durch
ein tee macht es euch gemütlich wir
steigen durch was ist momentan
eigentlich der korona masterplan
wir wissen inzwischen dass wir super
spreading events vermeiden müssen zum
beispiel feiernde menschen in
geschlossenen räumen aber auch
containment also eindämmung ist nach wie
vor wichtig containment heißt infektion
erkennen und infektionsketten
unterbrechen in der praxis heißt das
testen und kontakte verfolgen dann kann
man nämlich strenge schutzmaßnahmen wie
quarantäne auf infizierte personen und
deren kontakte beschränken während für
den rest der gesellschaft gilt keep calm
and carry on also dass der witz von
content wir schützen unsere gesundheit
und die unserer mitmenschen und stellt
gleichzeitig sicher dass das öffentliche
leben nicht komplett lahmgelegt wird
also containment gut doch die
kapazitäten um kontakte zu verfolgen und
zu testen sind begrenzt und wenn wir das
sprengen also wenn die behörden nicht
mehr hinterherkommen weil die
infektionszahlen zu hoch sind oder zu
schnell steigen dann kommen wir wieder
genau dahin wo wir schon im frühjahr war
nämlich dass sie wieder strenge
maßnahmen für alle einführen müssen oder
sogar noch da und seien so erstmal nur
lokale das wollen wir alles nicht
containment kapazitäten sprengen nicht
gut
irgendwas tun wir also um unsere
containment kapazitäten nicht zu
sprengen
ja grundsätzlich gibt es ja zwei
stellschrauben erstens infektionen
möglichst niedrig halten und zweitens
test nun kontakt verfolgung möglichst
weit ausbauen drehen wir es mal kurz
über die infektion und die
infektionszahlen steigen gerade wieder
langsam und das liegt nicht nur daran
dass wir mehr tests meine kollegen von
quarks haben das hier visualisiert ihr
seht ihr den anteil positiver tests im
verhältnis zur gesamtlänge dieser
pikiert es war der große turniers
ausbruch und dann geht es wieder runter
aber seit einer weile steigen die zahlen
langsam aber stetig ist das ein grund
zur panik nein denn auch wenn die
absoluten infektionszahlen ähnlich hoch
sind wie im märz als wir die schulen
geschlossen haben steigen die
infektionszahlen gerade deutlich
langsamer aber vor allem wegen des super
special events gibt es keine garantie
dass es so langsam bleibt also war super
es bei dem event auf einmal und schon
gibt es wieder ab
außerdem kommt er jetzt auch noch herbst
und winter das heißt wir sind bald nicht
mehr so viel draußen wo das
infektionsrisiko geringer ist deswegen
dürfen jetzt nicht in so eine spirale
rutschen nach dem motto wenn jetzt die
kitas wieder aufbauen kann ich auch
gleich wieder ins büro fand ich schon
wieder im büro bin kann ich auch wieder
fußball spielen gehen dann kann ich auch
ein konzert geht man rein alles was
vermeidbar ist sollte auch vermieden
werden denn jede vermiedene infektion
hilft gleichzeitig können wir natürlich
nicht alles vermeiden also das
öffentliche leben muss weitergehen und
zum beispiel die schulen und kitas
müssen wieder geöffnet werden weil die
schäden der schließung nicht mehr
tragbar sind deswegen müssen wir
gleichzeitig auch unsere containment
maßnahmen wussten hier ist ja schon viel
passiert es stehen mehr test zur
verfügung wir haben die korona war die
beiden kontakt verfolgen falls sie die
noch nicht installiert habt freunde der
sonne soll so gut es wurden sogenannte
containment scouts eingesetzt und die
gesundheitsämter zu entlassen und wenn
wir beim restaurantbesuch und so
kontakte hinterlassen ist das natürlich
auch eine konnten mit maßnahmen in
diesem video wollen wir aber ein fokus
auf die tests wegen und die frage wie
können wir mehr testen schöpfen wir
gerade alle denkbaren test kapazitäten
aus gehen wir das mal durch die korona
virus tests erst mal vielleicht ganz
kurz das grundprinzip der labortechnik
warte später noch wichtig wird also der
groner test also der standardtest ob man
gerade infiziert ist ist ein sogenannter
rt pcr tests manchmal sagt man auch nur
pcr-test rt pcr steht für reverse
transkriptase polymerase-kettenreaktion
und beschreibt eine labortechnik in
denen man viren rna isoliert die in dna
umwandelt und dann teile dieser dna
vermehrt ist das ganze sichtbar also
detektiert wird es gut an diesen pcs ist
dass sie verlässlich sind und auch
kleine virus konzentrationen noch gut
nachweisen können das schlechte ist dass
diese pcr tests im eigentlichen
tatsächlichen infektionsgeschehen immer
so ein bisschen hinterher hinken
denn inzwischen wissen wir dass man am
ansteckendsten ist kurz bevor man
symptome bekommt weil ich mich aber erst
testen lassen wenn ich schon symptome
habe habe ich bis dahin vielleicht schon
andere menschen angesteckt und wir
wissen dass corona oft auch mild oder
sogar symptomatisch verlaufen kann so
dass solche leute erst gar nicht
getestet werden obwohl sie
andere menschen anstecken können
eigentlich müsste man also viel
großflächiger und häufiger testen
präventiv testen also vorbeugend und
nicht erst wenn schon passiert ist
teilweise wird es auch gemacht zum
beispiel in krankenhäusern wenn man dann
stationär aufgenommen wird man erst
getestet einfach zur sicherheit auch bei
pflegeheimen hat sich
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn für
präventive reihen tests ausgesprochen
wäre der praxis werden die kaum gemacht
und bei schulen und kitas da präventiv
zu testen
es ist utopisch also das würde die
kapazitäten sprengen und wäre auch viel
zu teuer also geht sie eher tests
verlässlich aber teuer und langsam weiß
auch nicht warum ich so wie daumen in
diesem video benutzer aber was ist mit
antikörpertest antikörper das beruhe auf
einer anderen labortechnik wo nicht das
virus selbst angewiesen wird sondern ob
man antikörper gegen das virus im blut
hat antikörper test gibt es inzwischen
überall zu kaufen darunter auch schnell
test sie innerhalb von zehn minuten das
testergebnis anzeigen sollen antikörper
im blut werden oft als immunität
nachweis verstanden und es wäre ja auch
eine riesige erleichterung zu wissen
wenn man immun gegen korona wäre also
wenn man sich selbst und andere nicht
mehr anstecken könnte und eine
langfristige erleichterung wäre das im
gegensatz zu einem negativen virus test
der mir ja nur seit das ich aktuell
nicht infiziert bin könnte man da nicht
wenigstens großflächig antikörper test
durchführen
schließlich wäre es ja auch sehr
wertvoll zu wissen ob jemand in
systemrelevanten einrichtungen wie zb in
krankenhäusern oder in schulen ist das
problem ist dass antikörper tests für
die allgemeine bevölkerung nicht genau
genug sind und warum sie nicht genau
genug sind das müssen wir verstehen denn
auch wenn sich manche jetzt denken wann
kommt die alte zu den hoffnungsvollen
thaci redet ja immer noch über probleme
naja also ihr seht ja hier die kapitel
ihr könnte das überspringen aber tut es
nicht erstens können wir nur beurteilen
wie sinnig oder unser nicht irgendein
tests ist wenn wir so ein bisschen test
statistik verstehen
und zweitens wird genau diese tests
statistik immer wieder von
verschwörungstheoretikern falsch
dargestellt und die kommt damit
natürlich nur durch falls ich nicht
genug leute damit auskennen also seit er
am start
[Musik]
sensitivität und spezifität kein test
ist perfekt es wird immer falsche
ergebnisse geben aber es macht bei einem
falschen test einen wichtigen
unterschied auf welche art er falsch ist
sieht der grundsätzlich zwei mögliche
fehler entweder ist der test täglicher
weise positiv so ich habe dieses oder
jenes ist du hast nun auf ok oder das
ergebnis ist fälschlicherweise negativ
so moment den detektor sagt du hast
keinen hatte beide haben gemeinsam dass
sie doof sind aber unterschiedlich so
wenig einen falsch-positiven virus test
bekommen müsste ich unnötigerweise in
quarantäne gehen
bei einem falsch negativen test würde
ich mich in falscher sicherheit wiegen
und vielleicht jemanden anstecken für
den corona im schlimmsten fall
lebensbedrohlich werden könnte verdammt
doof bei einem antikörper test wäre es
anders herum da würde ein falsch
positiver tests zu einer falschen
sicherheit führen und das auch noch
langfrist da hatte der praxis so wichtig
ist diese beiden fehler zu unterscheiden
gibt es in der wissenschaft zwei
verschiedene größen erstens sensitivität
die sensitive ein test ist desto genauer
kann er infizierte personen korrekt als
positiv identifizieren
das heißt je höher die sensitivität ist
und weniger falsch negative ergebnisse
kriegt zweitens spezifität die spezi
sicher ein test ist desto genauer kann
er nicht infizierte personen korrekt als
negativ identifizieren das heißt je
höher die spezifität desto weniger
falsch positive ergebnisse kriegt man
beides wird in prozent angegeben zum
beispiel spezifität gleich 95% dann
bedeutet das dass unter den nicht
infiziert sind 95 prozent ein korrekt
negatives ergebnis bekommen fünf prozent
aber ein falsch positives so weit so
einfach aber jetzt kommt die wichtige
sache die viele missverstehen denn ich
bei einem 95 prozent spezifischen test
ein positives ergebnis bekomme heißt das
wohlgemerkt nicht dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieses ergebnis
korrekt ist
95 prozent beträgt sie könnte auch nur
50 prozent betragen klingt komisch ist
aber so die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ich mit einem positiven
testergebnis auch tatsächlich infiziert
bin nennt sich eher positiv prädiktive
wert abgekürzt mit ppw entrichtet
negativ prädiktive wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich tatsächlich
nicht infiziert bin wenn ich ein
negatives testergebnis kriegt diese
prädiktive werte ppg und entweder hängen
nicht nur von der spezifität und
sensitivität der tests ab sondern auch
von der häufigkeit der krankheit also
von der prävalenz klingt komisch ist
aber so ich meine entweder habe hier
guten oder schlechten gute texas sollte
doch nicht davon abhängen wie viel mut
trägerinnen es in deutschland gibt
doch und er werde auch das sehen warum
es gibt bei einem test ja grundsätzlich
für gruppen die anzahl der leute die
korrekt positiv getestet werden wie die
anzahl der leute die falsch positiv
getestet werden c die anzahl der leute
die falsch negativ getestet werden und
die anzahl der leute die korrekt negativ
getestet der positiv prädiktive wert ist
jetzt die anzahl der korrekt positiven
test geteilt durch die anzahl aller
positiven test dhbw ist gleich geteilt
durch a + b
denn negativ prädiktive wert ist die
anzahl der korrekt negativen
testergebnisse geteilt durch alle
negativen test ergebnisse dh npd ist
gleich d geteilt durch die +10 können so
sehr gut veranschaulichen wenn wir das
mal an einem konkreten beispiel für
einen antikörpertest durchrechnet
ideenhaus von einer prävalenz also einer
häufigkeit von einem prozent als ein
prozent der bevölkerung hat tatsächlich
antikörper gegen das virus im blut
wir haben einen antikörpertest mit einer
sensitivität von 94 prozent und einer
spezifität von 99% realistische annahmen
laut diesem artikel wo auch verschiedene
szenarien durchgerechnet werden sagen
wir wir testen damit jetzt eine
repräsentative bevölkerungsgruppe von
10.000 menschen ein prozent priwall
endzeit 100 menschen haben antikörper
die restlichen 9900 nicht die tests
sensitivität ist 94 prozent das heißt
vor den 100 leuten mit antikörpern
werden 94 prozent sprich 94 leute
projekt positiv getestet sechs leuten
lieferte test ein falsch negatives
ergebnis 94 und c ist sechs sohn unter
den 1900 menschen ohne antikörper werden
mit einer test spezifität von 99 prozent
auf 9 90 prozent der leute also 9800
1 leute korrekt negativ getestet die
restlichen 1 prozent also 99 leute
kriegen ein falsch positives ergebnis
strich ist 9800 1 und er ist 99 ähnlich
jetzt bei dieser messung ein positives
ergebnis erhalte dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich tatsächlich
auch antikörper im blut habe gerade mal
48,7 prozent die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
bestimmte so fdp dabei klingt eine
sensitivität von 94 prozent ohne
spezifität von 99% irreführend hoch wenn
ich allerdings ein negatives ergebnis
erhalte dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass das stimmt 99,9 prozent das heißt
ein negatives ergebnis ist ziemlich
sicher richtig ein positives ergebnis
hingegen gar nicht sicher genau das ist
auch tatsächlich das problem mit
antikörper tests die prävalenz der
krankheit fließt also sehr stark in
diese formel 1 kestermann mit dem
gleichen test ihr zum beispiel
risikogruppen wo die prävalenz höher ist
ist auch der ppp höhe aber für die
allgemeine bevölkerung ist ein positives
testergebnis deutlich weniger
verlässlich also negatives generell für
alle tests gilt nicht nur für antikörper
tests je seltener eine krankheit ist
desto mehr falsch positive ergebnisse
gibt es nun kann man dieses problem aber
abfangen und zwar mit einer richtig
hohen spezifität würden wir unserem
beispiel einen test nehmen mit einer
spezifität von 99,9 prozent statt nur 90
prozent
dann steigt der positiv prädiktive wert
von knapp 50 prozent auf 90 prozent die
pcr test also die normalen virus test
haben eine sehr hohe spezifität denn
damit ist es nicht ungewöhnlich dass man
auf eine spezialität von 100 prozent
kommt also so ein test funktioniert
natürlich auch bei kleiner priwall es
sei denn natürlich mein verpacktes
irgendwie zb indem er den rachenabstrich
nicht richtig macht was zu einem falsch
negativen ergebnis führt oder true story
aus den usa zu falsch positiven
ergebnissen bei der amerikanischen
gesundheitsbehörde cdc wurde eine
komponente der pcr test kit im gleichen
raum hergestellt wo auch echte probe des
virus untersucht wurden und anscheinend
ist dabei virus in einige der test kits
gelangt so dass manche test schon von
vornherein positiv waren
aber so lange sowas nicht passiert
können wir uns auch auf positive
ergebnisse der pcr tests verlassen falls
sie also im internet über irgendwelche
zahlen stolpert die behaupten wir hätten
eigentlich gar nicht so viele corona
infizierte das seien alles nur falsch
positive tests dann checkt noch mal ganz
genau deren quellen falls sie überhaupt
welche zum nachprüfen verlinken unsere
quellen sind wie immer unten zum
nachlesen in der beschreibung classic
ist damit abgehakt jetzt sind wir bereit
für die guten nachrichten
gruner schnelltests die neue hoffnung so
wir haben ja gerade gelernt ein crooner
test der ungenau ist bringt nichts und
jetzt will ich euch genau das gegenteil
zählen bluetooth käfers auf es gibt
derzeit immer mehr stimmen aus der
forschung die sich die krone
schnelltests einsetzen die eine ziemlich
schlechte sensitivität haben also eine
ziemlich hohe falsch negatives beispiel
es gibt in bestimmten im labor
schnelltest für gruner den sogenannten
id genau test der innerhalb von minuten
ausgewertet ist aber eine sensitivität
von gerade mal 52 prozent besitzt noch
allem was wir besprochen haben ist das
viel zu wenig und entsprechend hat man
auch direkt gesagt weg damit
beziehungsweise die medizinische
zulassungsbehörde in den usa hat für
diesen test eine warnung veröffentlicht
über die hohe gefahr von falsch
negativen ergebnis aber diese 52 prozent
sind nicht etwa zufällig verteilt
sondern der test wird vor allem dann
falsch negativ wenn die virus
konzentration also die viruslast unter
einen bestimmten wert fällt proben mit
geringer viruslast wären mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit falsch negativ
gemessen aber proben mit hoher viruslast
wären auch mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
korrekt positiv gemessen
in dieser studie hat man sich das
genauer angeschaut hier seht ihr eine
logarithmische auf tragung der viruslast
im verlauf der krankheit
sie steht anfangs sehr schnell an und
fällt dann langsam wieder ab die untere
pinkl linie das ist dass die diktion
slim mit der pcr tests elo de steht für
level of dictation die obere violette
linie das ist das test limit solcher
schnelltests in der springende punkt ist
dass man umso ansteckender ist je höher
die viruslast ist das führt uns zu einer
ziemlich attraktiven überlegung nämlich
dass diese doch sehr wenig sinn sie die
die aber schneller einfacher günstiger
sind als pcr test und deswegen auch viel
häufiger eingesetzt werden könnten
dass die ausreichen um menschen mit
hoher viruslast also personen von denen
auch ein hohes ansteckungsrisiko ausgeht
dass man die verlässlich erkennen kann
und die personen die der test nicht
erkennen kann sind ohnehin diejenigen
mit geringer viruslast von denen auch
ein entsprechend geringeres
ansteckungsrisiko ausgeht und es gibt
sogar schnelltest für die man noch nicht
einmal ein labor braucht wie diese
schwangerschaftstests artigen tests man
ja spuckt quasi auf einen teststreifen
und kurze zeit später wird das ergebnis
angezeigt diese papierstreifen sind mit
antikörpern versehen die auf bestimmte
teile des virus reagieren nämlich auf
die antigene des virus und diese anti
gen tests sind so günstig herzustellen
dass man ein streifen für 12 dollar
verkaufen könnte
versteht ihr was so günstiger und so
einfache tests für ein game changer sein
könnten stell dich vor bevor kinder in
die kita oder schule gehen spucken sie
beim eingang aufs contest und kinder mit
positivem ergebnis wären direkt nach
hause fische grobe aber häufig gestellt
es könnten an einstellen zum einsatz
kommen wo pcr tests zu langsam oder
teuer sind zum beispiel fängt ja bald
die erkältungssaison an und ganz viele
menschen werden ständig oder ähnliche
symptome haben aber nicht alle werden
pcr test bekommen darunter auch die
ganzen kita kinder die ohnehin ständig
amrum husten sind oder sagen wir es gibt
neuen krone fallen der schule dann
könnte man an dieser schule problemlos
über gewissen zeitraum täglich alle
durch testen um hochinfektiöse personen
sofort raus sie oder man könnte durch
schnelltest auch quarantäne zeiten
verkürzen also viele anwendungsgebiete
sind denkbar
natürlich sollten solche picken dirty
test nicht die genauen pcs ersetzen aber
ergänzen wenn man leute an ihren
ansteckendsten tagen erwischen könnte
könnte man neue ausbrüche im keim
ersticken
also schnell test selbst mit niedriger
sensitivität könnten genau die
zusatzmaßnahme seien dies braucht dass
wir im herbst und winter ein halbwegs
normales öffentliches leben führen
können ohne eine zweite welt zu
riskieren
also mich stimmt das alles
sehr hoffnungsvoll wohlgemerkt sind
diese anti gen tests derzeit noch nicht
zum kauf erhältlich also die müssten
erst in großen mengen produziert werden
deswegen hoffentlich ist gut aber nicht
vergessen
tests sind nur eine maßnahme von
mehreren jeder von uns trägt seinen teil
zum infektionsgeschehen bei sei es
positiv oder negativ und während wir
darauf warten dass schnelltest
vielleicht bald teil unseres alltags
werden haben wir mit unserem tätig zu
halten immer noch das meiste selbst in
der hand also nochmal sonst keine panik
schieben aber auch bitte nicht vergangen
wenn ihr das video hilfreich findet
helft uns bitte diese informationen zu
verbreiten teilte das video mit eurer
familie oder euren freunden hier
verlinke ich euch noch ein video von
meiner funkkolleg in doktor floro flores
ärzten und behandelt auf ihrem kanal
medizinische themen also wenn ich das
interessiert schaut er gerne mal vorbei
und hier verdiene ich euch noch ein
video von uns über statistik und darüber
wie wir mit zahlen und grafen
manipuliert werden können wir sehen uns
in zwei wochen und bis dahin bleibt
sicher